اسهم رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشيسوناك
ليست عاليه وسط البريطانيين وفق احدث
استطلاع لراي اجرته شركه الابحاث اذا تسعه
وخمسون في المئه من البريطانيين لا
يؤيدونك ولديهم مواقف سلبيه تجاهه بينما
يتمتع زعيم المعارضه ورئيس حزب العمال كير
بموقع افضل قليلا من سونيك مع نسبه تاييد
فقط
35% من المستطلعين اما حزب العمال فاحتل
مركزا اعلى من حزب المحافظين الحاكم في
الاستطلاع بنسبه تاييد بلغت واحد واربعين
في المئه مقابل 22 في المئه فقط للمحافظين
اجريت عمليه المسح في الرابع عشر والخامس
عشر من مايو الحالي وكان شارك فيها اكثر
من الفي شخص
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات